I actually have some good news for you
today farmers are furious with Donald
Trump now the reason that they're
furious is not good which is they're
getting crushed absolutely destroyed by
Donald Trump's tariffs and Trump's
pointless fruitless endless trade war
but the fact that the farmers are now
correctly blaming Trump for what Trump
did is a good thing
Trump's lies often work and frequently
they go unpunished
we have in front of us step one in
Donald Trump actually suffering the
consequences or suffering some
consequences from his lies which is that
farmers are identifying them as lies
this is step one step one is acceptance
Donald Trump's tariffs have led to
massive drops in a number of
agricultural exports soy beans pork
wheat a number of other farm exports now
the administration has tried to sort of
make up for this by subsidizing farmers
which sounds a lot like the socialism
that Donald Trump claims to be against
but okay anyway it's not been enough
farm bankruptcies are climbing farmers
are buying less and less farm equipment
so the manufacturers of the farm
equipment are starting to suffer the
problems are trickling up so to speak
and Donald Trump subsidies just aren't
cutting it
Donald Trump has now straight-up started
lying and saying farmers are doing great
again it's not true but much like the
China phone call that never happened
Trump realizing that things aren't going
well with the trade war and saying don't
worry
China's desperate to figure this out
they've called me to start trade talks
of course they haven't there was no such
phone call Donald Trump is simply saying
Oh things are going great for farmers
now and fortunately the farmers are
actually pushing back and the farm
groups are saying no things are not
going well quote from Brian Salman who
is the president of the Minnesota Corn
Growers Association there are dozens and
dozens of these groups Brian thälmann
saying we're not starting to do great
again things are going downhill and
downhill quickly will they vote as a
result of that we don't know but at
least they've correctly identified that
Donald Trump is lying the National
Farmers Union says Donald Trump's
tariffs are making things quote worse
not better
will they vote on the basis of that
understanding we don't know more and
more individual farmers like Bob colon
are saying I'm doing terribly since
Donald Trump came into office and it's
getting worse and worse so that's all
good this is just what we call step one
then it gets to where the rubber meets
the road will these farmers vote for a
Democrat in 2020 will they stay home we
heard from the same farmer Bob Cooley
into CNN quote if he doesn't lose he
being Trump if Trump doesn't lose 100%
of it from the farm belt then people are
kind of crazy because this is not going
well for farmers at all our farmers
going to vote for someone else our
lifelong Republican farmers in the
Midwest going to vote for a Democrat in
2020 I hope the answer is yes but I
don't know and this is something I've
been talking about for a long time just
because a lifelong Republican is
displeased with what Donald Trump is
doing or with some aspect of what Donald
Trump is doing doesn't mean they're
going to vote for a Democrat now that's
okay and I'll explain that in a moment
we actually had a phone call a couple
phone calls from Trumpets who say I
don't like that Trump hasn't built the
wall and I asked them it was Doug from
Jamaal in fact I remember I said to Doug
okay if Trump doesn't build the wall by
2020 are you not voting for him and he
said well no I mean okay I I probably
still would and more than likely the
reason he won't build the wall if he
doesn't is because of Democrats standing
in the way or whatever so it's really
important to understand that any
dissatisfaction you hear from these
lifelong reliable Republican voters with
Donald Trump it doesn't mean they're
going to vote for someone else but
here's the upside even if they just stay
home on Election Day it's not a bad
thing assuming that the left can get our
base out to vote in November of 2020
because let's be very very honest about
this if they haven't decide
did not to vote for Trump in 2020 by now
they're either voting for Trump or maybe
staying home with most of them the best
we can hope for is that they stay home
and that's okay because they're not
going to vote for a Democrat but the
reason why this is all okay and we
shouldn't worry too too much about these
farmers not voting for a Democrat is
that national elections are not won by
convincing people on the other side to
vote for your person in large numbers
right there cannot really be an election
where 130 million people vote or
whatever the number is flipped by
arguing with people and changing their
minds when half the country doesn't vote
it's about getting out the vote and then
will accept anything that depresses vote
on the right or splits the opposition
vote so I talked earlier this week Trump
has a primary challenger a Republican
former Republican Congressman Joe Walsh
is running in the primary maybe he will
eventually run as an independent will
some angry farmers in the Midwest
maybe opt to vote for Joe Walsh or stay
home as a result of that that would be
fine we would gladly accept that maybe a
few percent of the National Republican
electorate that isn't pleased will Trump
with Trump will choose to stay home
they're not going to vote for a Democrat
but they won't vote at all that still
helps us as long as we get our base out
this is the path to a win and these
farmers even if they don't vote can be a
part of turning what was in 2016 an
election that ultimately was decided by
75,000 or so votes in three states
just a few farmers staying home in
combination with us getting our base out
can actually make a difference maybe
some of them will actually go and vote
for the Democratic nominee I don't know
but we don't need them to do that is the
point